اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير نحييكم الى
بانوراما نناقش فيها هذا المساء
قائد فاغنيري يحذر من خسائر روسيه فادحه
هل روسيا مساعده للهجوم الاوكراني ام ان
صراع النخبه العسكريه يؤثر على خطط التصدي
وثائق ترامب السريه الى الواجهه مجددا كيف
ستؤثر على حملته وكيف سيستفيد منى في سوق
في حزبه الجمهوري
وسوي تعود الى تعليم الورقي هل سلبيات
تعليم الرقمي تطغى على ايجابياته
ونحييكم مشاهدينا ومتابعينا الى نقاش
ملفنا الاول يفجعيني رئيس مجموعه باجنرال
روسيا المسلحه وبتصريحات بدات مفاجاه
وخطيره اعتبر ان القوات الروسيه ستلقى
قريبا خسائر فادحه في ساحه المعركه في
حربها ضد اوكرانيا لافتا الى ان روسيا
تفقد حاليا بعضا من اراضيها لصالح القوات
الاوكرانيه رئيس مجموعه فاجنر توقع وفق
مقطع نشره على تيليجرام توقع اصدار مجلس
الدمى الروسي خلال شهرين او ثلاثه على
ابعد تقدير اوامر اعدام بحق جنرالاتروس
لمسؤوليتهم عن الاخفاقات المرتقبه وفق
قوله والتي قد تتسبب في احداث تمرد شعبي
روسي وتهم بريكوجين هيئه اركان الجيش
الروسي بالتخلي عن اراض في منطقه بيل قرود
الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا لصالح الاخيره وعرض
مشددا تدخل قوته عسكريه في منطقه اذا عجزت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن وقف الهجوم
الاوكراني على الاراضي الروسيه في المنطقه
وباشاره ربما الى العلاقه المتوتره مع
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعلن بريكوجين في
وقت سابق من الاسبوع الحالي عن اسر قوته
ضابطا روسيا هاجمت وحدته مقاتل فاجنر
وعاده ما يطلق بريكوجين تصريحات ينتقد
فيها هيئه الاركان العامه الروسيه التي
يتهمها بعدم توفير ذخيره كافيه لمقاتله
هل بدا الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد صحيفه
واشنطن بوست تجيب نقلا عن اربعه مسؤولين
اوكرانيين الهجوم المضاد بدا بالفعل
واشنطن بوست تحدثت عن هجمات اوكرانيه
مكثفه على خط المواجهه جنوب شرق البلاد
وتقول الصحيفه ان الهدف هو تحرير مدينتي
متابعه هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا
المستشاره السياسيه في مركز الدراسات
الدوليه واهلا بك ومن العاصمه الدنماركيه
سامر الياس اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام واسمحوا
لي ان ابدا من موسكو معك
من جديد واهلا بك من جديد في بانوراما
السيده ايلينا في الواقع تصريحات تستوقف
دائما الكل ليس فقط الاوكرانيين ليس فقط
المتابعين ولكن حتى الروس يقول البعض بان
بريكوجين فضح ما لم تفضحه خلافات ومعارك
اخرى خاضتها روسيا هل هذه المعارك او هذه
التصريحات بالاحرى تضر بالعمليه العسكريه
الروسيه
مرحبا بكم تحياتي للجميع كما ارى هذه
التصريحات لا تضر
لتضر العمليه العسكريه الروسيه ابدا
والقوات الروسيه الان تصد الهجوم
الاوكراني وهناك خسائر فادحه على هذا
اوكرانيا ولكن تصريحات
خطيره من ناحيه السمعه الروسيه وسمعت
القوات الروسيه
وهي متضاربه في كثير من الاحوال انا
متاكده ان جزئيا بعض هذه التصريحات تاتي
في اطار الخدع العسكريه ولكن في جزء الاخر
هي تعكس وجود خلافات ما بين السيد بريجوجن
وبعض الجنرالات
وهناك يمكن سبب ثالث لهذه التصريحات يمكن
طموحات صيد السياسيه ممكن سنرى هذا الشيء
قبل الحمله الانتخابيه في سنه
2024 انا لا استبعد ذلك
نعم هي تصريحات متضاربه هي لا تؤثر عسكريا
اما تؤثر معنويا على بعض الناس سيد
سامر هل تتفق مع ضيفتي بانه هذه التصريحات
تاتي في اغلبها كما تقول هي ضمن الخدعه
العسكريه بان تصريحات قد تكون لها اهداف
سياسيه وبان هذه التصريحات في النهايه
يمكن ان تضر بالسمعه ولكن لن تضر باي شك
من الاشكال العمليه العسكريه
تحيه طيبه لكريم للسيده الينا وللمتابعين
الكرام لا اعتقد بان لا اتفق بالمطلق مع
السيده لينا صديقتنا بانه لدى بيريجوجن اي
امكانيه للصعود في السلم السياسي في روسيا
شخصيه شعبويه تعمل
باعاز من الكريم
لا تتجاوز الخطوط الحمراء ويكفي ان يحرك
الرئيس يده مره واحده حتى ينتهي بريجوجل
ويختفي من هذه الساحه كان هناك حاجه لبرجن
في المعارك نظرا لان الجيش الروسي اخفق في
تحقيق مهماته في العام الماضي في بدايه
الحمله العسكريه تم الاستعانه بهم منذ شهر
مارس اذار من العام الماضي
للقيام بعمليات الهجوم بريجوجن مطلوب من
اجل عمليات الهجوم بشكل اساسي لان الخسائر
هنا لا تحسب باي شكل من الاشكال لا يمكن
لاحد ان يحسب حساب السجناء قتلوا في هذه
المعارك لانه اما لديهم
اهالي بشكل كبير يسالون عنهم
وايضا لان عددا من الجنود في باغينر هم
ممن اختاروا مهنه القتل ومهنه الحرب ولذلك
هم ذهبوا وتطوعوا في هذه المجموعات لذلك
لهم له اغراض اعتقد بانه لن يكون هناك
تاثير كبير على العمليه العسكريه نظرا لان
الجيش الروسي هو الذي يصد عاده هجومات
وبينما تكلف عمليات الهجوم واقتحام
المواقع الاوكرانيه بقوات احمد سيره كما
شاهدنا في مريول لقوات بريغوجين كما
شاهدنا في سوليدار في في مريوبا وكما
شهدنا ايضا في الاونه الاخيره عندما تم
احتلال مدينه مخموت من قبل القوات الروسيه
لكن هو شخصيه شعبويه تحاكي ما يقوله الروس
بان الجيش الروسي عظيم وروسي عظيمه لكن
هناك خراطيه قاتله هناك فساد هذا الجيش
هزم بان جنرالاته ليسوا على قدر المسؤوليه
ويجب محاكمتهم ومحاسبتهم بينما نحن قادرون
على فعل ذلك هو لا يمكن ان يكون لا وزير
دفاع
ولكن هذه التصريحات قد تكلف كذلك بالاشاره
الى ذلك صيدليه قد تكلف الجيش الروسي
سمعته وايضا وهنا سؤال سيده يلينا ما يقوم
به بريغوجين لماذا يتحمله بوتر لماذا
تتحمل روسيا وهذا قد يشير الى ضعف الجيش
الروسي يعني بمعنى ان بوتين مضطر الى
الابقاع على بريجوجن الى الابقاع على
فاجنر لان الجيش الروسي غير قادر على
الهجوم غير قادر على فعل ما يفعله
هذا ما كنت اقصده
وانا ارى بان كل افعال سيد بريجوجل وكلامه
وكل هذا لا يتعارض مع افكار بوتين
المشاركه في الحياه السياسيه من بالنسبه
لا تعني تماما ابدا لا تعني المنافسه
للسيد بوتين
ومواله للسيد بوتين بشكل كامل
وبالفعل يحترم الخطوط الحمراء ولكن هذا لا
يمنع ان يشارك في الحياه السياسيه كان
عندنا ولكن ليس فقط في
خصوصي ساده ولكن ليس فقط في نقطه الخوض في
مجال السياسي اتحدث على الزام الابقاء
عليه لماذا ملتزم بوتين بالابقاع عليه
بعيدا عن الخطوط السياسيه اتحدث في هذه
المعركه العسكريه هل الابقاء عليه يشير
الى ضعف الى هزاله الجيش الروسي
لا انا اعتقد ان هذا الامر منسق مع رئيس
بوتين نفسه وهو يستفيد وهو يضعف بعض
الاحيان الاشخاص معينه اذا اراد ان يفعل
ذلك هو يعطي يمكن رسائل بعض الاحيان
منوهه
للطرف لطرف العدو وايضا هذا ياتي في اطار
التضليل والتمويه هذا الامر ايضا وارد وفي
بهذا السبب مسموح لسيد بريجوجل اكثر
بكثير مما مسموح له للاخرين بالاضافه
لعمله العسكري وهو جيد
وفصائل فاقدر تابع لسيد هي مدربه بشكل جيد
ولكنني كنت بدي اقول انه مثلا على مسرح
السياسي يا روسي هناك فارغ بعد وفاه السيد
لادمير جيري نوفسكي رئيس الحزب الليبرالي
الديمقراطي اذا ام تتذكروا هو شارك عده
مرات في الانتخابات الرئاسيه ولكن ليس لكي
يشكل منافسه حقيقيه للرئيس بوتين اما لكي
يصوت له بعض فضلا للشعبيته والى اخره فهذا
المكان الان فارغ استطلاعات الراي العام
تشير الى انه
على اقل لدى بعض الناس قد احتل هذا المكان
جديد هذا الينا وطرحتي نقطه المطامع
السياسيه او طموح السياسي
سامر قبل الوصول الى هذه المرحله المتقدمه
ربما في هذه الفتره في هذه المرحله ونحن
نتحدث عن امكانيه ان يكون هناك هجوم مضاد
اوكراني في ظل هذه التصريحات في ظل هذه
الانتقادات من بريكوشن لقيادات الجيش
الروسي كيف سيكون مسار هذا الهجوم الى اي
مدى روسيا قادره على التصدي الى امكانيه
ان يكون هناك هجوم مضاد اوكراني
الجانب الروسي يعتمد على الجيش النظامي في
صد الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني وليس على قوات
فاجنر وقوات احمد سيلا الشيشانيه بشكل
اساسي لذلك لن يكون هناك تاثير كبير
باستثناء التاثير على معنويات الجنود
الروس منذ ايام اعتقال واحتجاز احد الضباط
الروس من قبل قوات فاجنر وهي السابقه
خطيره جدا بكل المعايير نظرا لانها تجاوزت
خطوط حمراء كثيره في السابق كان ينتقد
قيادات الجيش
ودراسه وكان قد وجه لهم شتائم مهينه بشكل
كبير ولكن يوم الحديث يتم
اعتقال
جنود او ضباط من الجيش الروسي وهي نقطه
خطيره جدا عنها معنويات الجانب الروسي
الجانب الاوكراني ماضي في العمليه في
الهجوم مضاد ربما يكون هذا الهجوم قد بدا
بعده اماكن في سواء في محمود سواء باتجاه
كما شاهدنا اليوم وتمكن الروس من صد
بدايات هذا الهجوم
ايضا هذا الهجوم الاوكراني بدا في شهر
مايو ايار عندما هاجمت اوكرانيا مناطق في
مناطق حدوديه في بيلوجرات وفيبريانس وبنى
تحتيه في داخل الجانب الروسي لبث الدور
بين الروس العامل الاساسي ربما في نجاح
لجوم المضاد هو كيفيه استخدام الاوكرانيين
للاسلحه الحديثه والخطه العسكريه التي تم
وضعها كان هناك اكثر من سيناريو لكن اليوم
ذهب احد السيناريوهات بعد تفجير سد كخوفكا
وهو الهجوم من اتجاه خرسون وربما كان هو
الاقل احتمالا لكن الان روسيا تركز جوده
على اربع جبهات وهناك امكانيه لصد هذا
الهجوم نظرا لان القوات المهاجمه بحاجه
الى اربعه او خمسه اضعاف عدد الجنود
للقيام بالعمليه العسكريه على اوجه على
اكمل وجه اضافه الى استخدام الصواريخ
الغربيه لضرب المواقع الخطوط الخلفيه
الروسيه السيده هيلينا هل
في مرحله من المراحل منذ بدايه العمليه
العسكريه ان ناتي لهذه المرحله في حديثنا
عن امكانيه ان يكون هناك
رد فعل اوكراني بمحاوله هجوم اوكرانيا على
مناطق سيطرت عليها روسيا تتذكرين منذ
بدايه متابعتنا للعمليه العسكريه الروسيه
كنا نتحدث عن امكانيه ان تسيطر روسيا على
كيف ان تسيطر على خطوط شرايين مهمه
هنا ونحن نتحدث عن امكانيه رد اوكراني
واسترجاع لاراضي اوكرانيا من يتحمل
المسؤوليه
كانت هناك
اخطاء في بدايه هذه العمليه نحن تحدثنا عن
هذا الشيء عده مرات انه
روسيا راهنت على العمليه الخاطفه تستمر
بضع التسابيح ولكنها طالت ولكن انا اعرف
او اعتقد بانه على القياده العسكريه
الروسيه كانت تدرس كل السيناريوهات بما
فيها
سيناريوهات غير ايجابيه
فهذا الامر ايضا كان موجود فكانوا يراهنون
على افضل السيناريو ما تم تنفيذها ولكنهم
كانوا يحضرون انفسهم للسيناريوهات غير
ايضا نعم صعبه هي بدات ان تتطور في كثير
من الاحوال بشكل مفاجئ ولكنني اعتقد انه
القوات الروسيه كانت على الاقل القياده
العسكريه تحاول ان تتحضر لهذا الشيء سيدي
سامر هل تعتقد بان هذا سناريو كان مرتقب
كان منتظر ومن المستفيد بحسب قراءتك من
المستفيد من اطاله امد الحرب
يعني بطبيعه الحال لا اعتقد بان جانب
الروسي كان يدرس امكانيه ان يكون هناك حرب
طويله الجانب الروسي كان يعتمد على حرب
خاطفه كما جرى في عام 2008 في جورجيا او
على حرب على
2014 في القرن من دون عمليات عسكريه واسعه
لكن من المؤكد ان الصمود الاوكراني كان
مفاجئا بالنسبه للجانب الروسي اضافه الى
التزويد اوكرانيا باصناف مختلفه من
الاسلحه الغربيه بشكل تصاعدي وتجاوز كل
مرحله الخطوط الحمراء الروسيه هذا سيناريو
بطريقه الحال هو لا يصب لا في مصلحه روسيا
ولا في مصلحه اوكرانيا يصب في مصلحه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بشكل اساسي
التي استطاعت ان تعيد اللحمه بين
الاطلسي في القاره العجوز وبين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وتجبر البلدان
الاوروبيه بسبب الخوف من روسيا واجتياح
روسيا ان تزيد الموازنات الدفاعيه الى
اكثر من اثنين في في بعض الاحوال والى
العوده الى موضوع الدفاع وفرض عقوباته
الاقصى على روسيا في التاريخ البشري لذلك
هذا السيناريو لم يكن موجودا اليوم ما
يجري ربما ويقوم به بريغوجوشن هو تحضير
الراي العام الروسي ايضا لحرب طويله ان
اتذكر مارجريتا في بدايه الحرب كانت تقول
يومين او ثلاثه يمكن ان نسيطر على كيف
ولكن لا نريد تدمير المدن الاوكرانيه
الجميله لاحقا هي اقرت منذ ايام بان هناك
صعوبات كبيره في العمليه العسكريه
تحضر لعمليه طويله وتحضر بان روسيا يمكن
ان لا تحقق انتصارات كما كان موعودا في
السابق بانهاء اسلحه اوكرانيا بانهاء
النازيه
برفع الخطر عن سكان
هذه العمليه اود شكركم جزيل الش
كر وكل ما تفضلتم به من تحليل من موسكو
لنا سوبولينا المستشاره السياسيه في مركز
الدراسات الدوليه شكرا لك ومن العاصمه
الدنماركيه الصحفي المتخصص في شان الروسي
سامر الياس شكرا لكما
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات